who would make the ultimate karaoke duet
partner
most likely to get a tattoo with who you
choose to be stuck on an island with hmm
i felt pressure could i want on an
island
all right gather round class good
morning esteemed colleagues loyal fans
and every fabulous guest throughout this
season you are all a part of the
graduating class of the kelly clarkson
show congratulations we did it
season three is wrapping up and it has
definitely been one for the books
literally i
loved yearbook time like i loved
everybody signing them i love like what
will they say
i loved all of it i loved doing
everyone's i love that there was always
that person that was like i signed your
crack like in the center like and you're
like no one's done that before
here is ours this is the kelly clarkson
show here but class of season three
here we go
oh my gosh this is amazing
this is amazing
[Music]
look at all this is awesome season three
fun facts we filmed 180 episodes i sang
169 karaokes
i had
1027 guests that's insane two sports
emmys for the last season that's your
damn right even if the sports part was a
mistake i don't think it was a mistake i
think god knew
he knew what was going on we were
nominated for nine new emmys for this
season which was exciting and it really
is exciting like my team works really
hard and everyone here is super cool
like
no joke you know like we've all had jobs
where you're like i would never barbecue
with that person like i would legit have
a drink or barbecue with everyone here
because everyone's cool and everybody's
here for like a good reason so anyway i
love my team
apparently i said you're welcome
1011 times
i competed in 28 games
and i only won 15 of them this is this
must be the feeling like that blake has
on the voice
cause you know i was eight seasons in
one fourth so
fifty percent of the time you made
millions of people smile every day and
for that we thank you oh that was nice
that was so nice it's celeb superlative
time let's play
[Music]
so the first one is life of the party
[Music]
100
this is going to alexa mccarthy she and
her husband i feel like they both like
they just seem like a rad time at their
house and like they might embarrass
their children and make the most amazing
way so
she is getting life for the party
everyone loves her that's the life of
the party that's who deserves that
someone that everyone agrees on as a
human and also
i told my son
who is obsessed
with ghostbusters with all the girls
with melissa and all them i was like oh
yeah she lives next door you know and he
about lost his mind life of the party
goes to melissa mccarthy look how
beautiful she looks hey
that's my neighbor won't you be my
neighbor yes she will be
she has no choice
she lived there first and i moved in
most likely to secretly be a superhero
in real life
oh
that's a good one
well i don't want to pick a superhero
who plays because i feel like that would
be the obvious
most likely to play a superhero
in real life i'm going
with sandra bullock
i feel like she's so cool
and above all of us it's like
that she would be the one to have some
kind of superpower and keep it on the
down low because she's cool like that
shouldn't need to brag about it because
she's so awesome i feel like that would
be sandy i called her sandy i don't know
her that well but i feel like i'm just i
just invited myself
to call her sandy
[Laughter]
sandra bullock i love her
okay wait am i skipping one no
most likely to get the teacher
kelly off topic most likely to get us
off to i'm gonna say this is probably
that's who's that's who this is king
michael key he is definitely most likely
to get me off topic in an interview but
that's because he's so fun
and i think we're both like adhd
so like
i feel like we're both like squirrel and
then we like change our path
very quickly
um so most likely to get the teacher
kelly off topic that goes to keegan yeah
most likely to beat me in a game hmm
well a lot of people did beat me i think
you just pointed that out
um
hmm
most likely to beat me in a game
i'm gonna go with tyler
i'm gonna go tyler perry i think he's
yeah coming in with intelligence wit
charisma i feel like he would beat me at
a game i feel like he's that guy that i
would just be so frustrated
and i'd want to beat so but but i also
feel like he's the guy i'd want to be
on a team with
that's right
i like tyler
i love the lasers in the background
hey
who you choose to be stuck on an island
with
interesting
now i'm gonna want someone to be able to
know how to like
possibly get me off the island
i get to pick two
okay well i'm cheating because i'm
actually gonna pick
keanu and carrie i'm gonna pick these
two as one because it's one picture
frame
because i feel like keanu he's just fun
hang if you're stuck on an island why
not be with some dude that's like
totally cool and like chill and be like
man we're stuck on an island and we just
figure it out and i also think carrie
like yeah i think she would be some
smart person that would know like what
fruit you could eat or not i don't know
she just comes off as incredibly
intelligent so does keanu why would you
not want the people from matrix on an
island with you is what i'm saying also
hmm
who am i gonna want
i felt pressure
i wanted an island i'm going to say
channing i'm going to say channing tatum
you know what i'm going to say channing
well there's the obvious
of why you want to be stuck on an island
shannon and then but really my real
reason is i feel like he would be handy
like i want people that that can help me
on the island like i feel like keanu i
feel like kerry and i feel like channing
i feel like we'd all make a team that
would somehow survive i feel like we
would be able to survive
and i feel like he would be really smart
and i feel like he would be really
strong so help me build
a treehouse channing
i feel like that would be a good team
okay there we go
keanu kerry and channy
yeah
who would make the ultimate karaoke duet
partner
kate hudson
turns out i had no idea and i saw kate
on that's my jam i did that's my jam
with a different crew
because the obvious would be to say
ariana we've done that before but i was
just saying kate she's saying like like
this really cool like 40s vibe with an
ariana song and i was really into it
kate
i was like okay i see you
it was really good anyway
and then i remembered she did you're so
vain
and
had to lose a guy in 10 days that was
awesome
bet you think this when she like drunk
it was that movie is so great
oh my god or she was angry maybe that's
what it was
okay yes
most likely to get a tattoo with
oh man i feel like that'd be a lot of
people i feel like okay so i think
tattoo i think i'm gonna go most likely
to get a tattoo with i think cynthia and
i i mean she just looks rad look at the
piercings like i feel like she's game
for like a good tattoo watch her be like
100 against it but
i feel like she'd be fun to get tattoos
with i feel like if she gets piercings
that cool we should get some art
i just want to hear her sing while we
get it
she'd be like get a musical tattoo
we had some cool guests y'all
so this season has been so great
we have such a great team we haven't
been able to see everyone people started
to take off their master stories and i
was like that's what they look like like
it's like because this whole literally
in season one covets started so like
it's been a weird kelly clarkson show
for the past three seasons but i feel
like it's been getting better each
season and everybody who works here
really does their best and it brings
their a-game and everybody does a really
good job and i feel like we put together
a show and that was our goal that can
let people escape and be happy and lift
up people that you know i feel like in
the news we always hear the bad stuff
and it's been nice to highlight all
these amazing
rad humans you know across the world and
that's been really really fun to do
because i feel like we've all needed
that so that's my favorite part honestly
um
of this season and every season i love
that the celebrities hang out we have a
panel show and a hangout with everybody
that's on the show they help bring their
spotlight to all these other
organizations we get to lift them up and
highlight them and tell people about
them and the domino effect of that is
incredible and we've heard back from
people that it's incredible so thank you
for watching we can't wait for season
four we're very excited all right so let
me know in the comments what your
favorite moments were from season three
i cannot wait to read them
and subscribe to my channel because
season 4 is coming and you just wait
all right have a great summer y'all
class dismissed
[Music]
you